hello and welcome to the life advice
podcast from your friends at gamespot
I'm giantbomb.com I'm your host Daniel
O'Dwyer joined by mr. Daniel Bryan
you've got questions it's a good thing
we've got dancers i knows how you doing
my friend yeah you enjoyed it yeah yeah
I've never this is the first video
component we've ever done for dancing oh
oh we currently whatever yeah because
they don't know what you're doing when
you're giving the dancers no we're naked
yeah yeah naked and just just dance yeah
and joined the whole time for two hours
dancing for dancers and we've got to put
your questions okay I from the folks
gamespot in giant bomb that's awesome I
bet life okay you're a person who's had
an interesting life you you you
basically reach your dreams you've had a
difficult time with your injuries and
whatnot do you think you have enough
wisdom for internet strangers to ask you
questions absolutely not but let's go
forward and right let's do it at first
question and this is from a done onimous
okay his donna nimah d is very important
yes yeah absolutely questions on the
internet and I hate vacations it's just
a matter of personal preference and not
much else but I want to stay at home and
play video games a lot I maintain a
fairly healthy lifestyle clearly he
means not very little but my parents
insist on essentially calling me lazy
bum and my ideal vacation is having some
freedom in a long time this winter break
all I want to do is shut myself in a
play video games how should i go about
convincing them uh so i think you're
going about life in a completely wrong
manner there's so much more to life than
what's in like these little screens that
you I mean there's this like very real
world that the rest of your senses can
like feel like if you just do this like
you can feel the touch tonight yeah yeah
you can get antsy i can tell you it and
now when i do it to you whoa do you feel
it and now here we are just two dudes
touching each other having a good time
and so like you could go out and do that
on vacation and it'll be fun and you can
get some Sun on your face and you can
you know start exploring life and cuz
you
want to die in front of the screen let's
get it it's a really great answer to
have it a video dancer it's a dancer did
great you dr. a great dancer we don't we
don't you know your own Philly full of
[ __ ] I'm very you know rattlesnake
Texas rattlesnake he's on front of the
box he's not a person I've asked this
question I'm very very happy here and
this is from I on Twitter it says dear
dance should i ditch my bangs are not
and i will be forever grateful for your
advice in this Harry predicament yeah so
um I don't do whatever you want man I
think bangs are cool if you dig bangs
rock your bangs man a little why don't
you have this I don't know it just grows
like I don't I don't do anything with it
is you know like you like oh there's no
endgame atures either ever there's
plenty of heads yeah I had a shaved head
in WWE yeah it so I had a shaved head
and a beard and my wife hated the shave
and Ted with the beard look she said you
have to go your hair if you want to keep
the beard I just started doing my hair
and now it's like this is that an
ultimatum she didn't expect not to be
the wreck you my agent she didn't expect
at all she was thinking he's gonna shave
the beard great fiction games yeah I
provice yourself and actually Peter
Wilson asked a question and should I
shave my head absolutely not unless you
really want to shave your beard if
somebody else is trying to force you to
shave your beard like your boss like if
you need if you need it to look good for
your job you know screw those people you
don't need a job you don't need money
Yeah right do what you want that girly
but hearing but if you want if you want
to shave because who knows why maybe you
just like like we said earlier if you
like the sensation if you're just like
feeling your clean and paid no you can't
if you just like feeling your clean face
then yeah then then shave it but
otherwise man we're men I'm a man in
tights go beard yeah that's a fair point
yeah they have rosslyn cut your beard no
no no you like a beard physics Bray
Wyatt's beard physics in the last game
real impressive yeah beer that you
impressed when you look when you see
yourself games a remind you of your bed
physics yeah and you know what in the
new game two they got my hair physics
down great yeah awesome and next
question and this is
from the nonnamous again okay i'ma show
ya dinama deez nutz and this is asking
our friends are you brave fellow friends
yeah yeah yeah I just meant this might
work and so I've known this girl for
nearly six years now we've been best
friends almost the whole time since we
went high school I've always had a bit
of a thing for her but never pursued it
if high school she was dating my best
friend at the time crucial point and now
she's been single for several years now
right close friends don't even joke
about getting married some thick you
know it's a way to get Mac is joking
about it yeah yeah i really want to ask
her out on a date but I'm rarely I
really get to see her and don't want to
ruin a great friendship is it weirded me
to ask where considering that's used to
date me I mean I don't think so and and
you know what I do this if are you as if
Q mind I've never drank in my entire
life I'd get drunk and I'd kiss her
right and then just say hey I was drunk
oh so it's like again ever yeah if they
could get out it's like oh I'm so if she
doesn't like it if she likes it and it's
like hey cool yeah we're up but it's
just like hey hey let's go out let's go
do something let's have fun okay now
we're both drinking okay now gah he said
so you're saying like my lifetime of
drinking over the drinking is actually
the ultimate dancer this entire time
yeah for this specification and you my
mind you have no idea how many times
like I thought man if I were drunk I
could really just go for right now yeah
blame it on the drunkenness but as
somebody who doesn't drink I can't do
that so when I did the thing me and bri
we're friends first so then I just had
to be like hey
I'm gonna kiss you now and that's you
know the workout yeah yeah I'm married I
got ya did it work out last question a
very important one this is also from
synonymous actually and it's a running
team nobody ever disappears and some
guys have just broken into my house and
are attempting to steal my playstation 4
and copy of WWE 2k16 should I you just
wait for this year's games come out or
should i intervene any help appreciated
okay as somebody who chased down
burglars who broke into his house and
I'm going to tell you it's a very bad
idea I was very lucky because they did
not have weapons me and you guys in the
UK don't have as many gun that's true
now that they still have like knives and
stuff like that and other stuff you know
and like they tell us like hey you
shouldn't have even chased those guys
you never know what could happen that
said you just have to do what your
instinct tell you I mean I'm just one
I'm just one Dan you're just another day
yeah we don't have all the dancers okay
we tell me so no we don't have all of
them sometimes you just have to make
your own decisions Samuel I appreciate
it talking to you and when are we gonna
see back in the ring how you feeling I I
have no idea no but if even if I never
get back in the ring again you can
always play me like WWE 2k16
you